I'm just going to grab this Yubi key real quick.
One moment please.
Do you guys use these Yubi keys for work?
Which one?
Yubi keys are secure like sign in with your applications and stuff.
Nope, I don't bother with that.
It's like if I lose it, I can't even get into my laptop.
So I was like, where did that little piece go?
That's a very expensive piece of hardware to take care of then.
I'd have to call in a new laptop that takes three days.
I'd lose three days of work just for a small little widget, right?
Hi, Pam. How are you?
How's it going?
Yeah, doing well.
How about yourself? You doing well?
Yep.
Nice. Nice. Okay, great.
Well, I know we have about 45 minutes here.
I think the teams are roughly briefed on both ends,
but maybe we could just do some brief introductions for two minutes
and we can kind of get started with the contacts.
I think both parties know us.
So, you know, for them,
would you all like to maybe get started on your side with introductions
and then maybe Pam can introduce herself and we can get started?
Hey, Pam. Good morning.
Much of this site, I look out into our partnership ecosystem over here at Short-Hills.
We even formed for quite one and a half year now almost.
Started out as a cybersecurity consultant with E-Vite.
They sent over there for quite some time.
Then transitioned into more of a consulting piece and then moved.
I did that for US customers for about two, three years
and then transitioned into a partnership ecosystem.
I was primarily looking into data analytics and the IA.
At that point of time,
it was, Chai Teebity was just coming around the corner.
The murders were not really out on the market.
Were you working on this before when we used to have to use like high torch
and like open CV and stuff like that?
High torch and Mistral were the older pieces that, you know, were,
there was one more thing that was very popular,
gained a lot of traction with the developers,
but they kind of died out once these policies were implemented.
Right. But that's what I had to learn on because I learned before just like,
you know, that wasn't around.
So we had to like make our own, you know.
I was experimenting with PyTorch.
So me and my friend, we were quite firm.
We were just trying things out.
Hey, this is such an interesting piece of hardware.
Yeah.
It's such an interesting piece of thing that you can play around with.
He always had a source for another one.
I failed to recall his name.
He had a source for that one.
Yeah, I know.
And like we use like, it's like usually open CV, PyTorch and this other third,
the third one that I can't think of right now that I'm pretty sure.
But yeah, there's a lot of fun.
Yeah.
So if you look around the junkies,
TensorFlow, sorry, TensorFlow was one of the other ones.
TensorFlow, TensorFlow. Yeah, TensorFlow.
He had a source for TensorFlow.
Yeah.
And I was like, hey, why are you so crazy about TensorFlow?
And he's like, hey, dude, this, this, this new thing that TensorFlow is just
really, hey, this is just, this is just off the shelf.
This is just come out.
Yeah, exactly.
Those are the crazy days now.
Hey, you don't have to do this.
It's easier, right?
But like when I originally had a homework project on TensorFlow and I went and I
couldn't understand it really.
It was like my first time and someone told me this is going to take 20,
20 hours.
And I was like, what?
And I was like, it takes like a long time to do what that LLM just does in two seconds.
So yeah, would love to understand a little bit more about what you're,
let's see, I have a little bit of a gist about what you're looking to have,
but would love to hear more from it from such as in the horses mouth to understand
more about your vision, what you're looking to achieve.
And at the end of the day, what is it that you're looking to close up?
What is the end goal that you're looking to have?
What is the, the things that you're looking to have in place?
The, the idea was really, and that's like, what's, what's an anonymous autonomous
system and really how do you set that up and really what's a smart system, right?
And so a system that can just call an LLM every time and just do that.
It's not really a smart system for me, right?
Cause you're just, you're calling LLM, you're doing that.
You're not like, it can't flow by itself, agentically, right?
But if I have an agent that goes in and finds every time it calls that LLM API and then
it takes that and it distills it into its knowledge base, right?
Next time it comes to finding that pattern, well, it's set up in this way.
The agent is set up in this way where there's three levels to it, right?
So the first, the first path, the first level is, is this, is this security, is my guardrails?
Like that's always number one, like whatever's going on at level is always checking those guardrails
and every system is going to have different guardrails, right?
So that's guardrails meaning like, you have the right credentials, that's guardrails.
Like, is this my system overflowing right now?
Is this, is this reading to LLM tree right now that like is a simple, like it needs to shut off the system.
Right?
On off.
So they're simple, like if then statements really simple coded.
We, when we weren't doing data bricks, we were like, okay, we're going to do this in Rust, right?
Because it takes really, it's going to be an MCP and your agents are going to be one in the MCP is the other.
The Rust is going to be that first layer that's always listening to what's going on.
And then it's going to move up to the second layer.
It's going to take, okay, whatever the inputted to that prompt.
Is this a, is this a pattern I've seen before?
Have I asked this question before and gotten an answer and can I use it again?
Okay.
And then if it does, it just does that.
It doesn't call the API.
And so you, you're what you're doing is you're saving tokens, you're saving time and it's getting smarter, right?
Because it's learning what to do on by itself.
And the more that it runs, well, the more solutions it's solving and the more solutions it's then being able to save.
And then the less times you're running the API, you're saving tokens, right?
So it's meant to your savings tokens.
It's getting smarter and it's getting cheaper, right?
And those are all those things that we want right now in AI because of the data centers, right?
Because of what we're doing to the environment, like that the AI guzzles more water these days than we do, right?
That AI takes more water than we do.
And so there's got to be a way that you design agents that don't work like this, because if you just go on design agents like this,
and it's just one idea that we had, which was basically, you know, that everybody jumped on board,
that everybody's agent like sort of looks like a light change, right?
It's got that prompt, it's got the thing, right?
But what if we were just like, wait, we were building this wrong?
And we went back to robotics and we went, well, robotics, we already did this.
We did this all, but we made these mistakes before and that building real life representations of things that were, it becomes clunky, right?
And so subsumption architecture and inactivism and cognitive, cognitive and body cognition, right?
Where things become decoupled and decentralized.
So you're looking at like the brain and you're looking at, okay, well, when my hand goes on the stove, right?
It doesn't think, it doesn't go to the LMM to think.
It's got to do something really quick.
It's not going to, right?
So why don't we design, so suspension architecture is this, where tasks are based on tasks, based on tasks, right?
So the most important tasks come first, right?
Because they need to be cleared first before you can do anything.
So like if your robot's on the wall and stuck on the wall, it can't roam the round, right?
So it's checking first, okay, is my bump sensor?
Is it knocked?
Okay.
If it's not, I've got to figure out how to get out of this.
Is it not knocked?
Okay, I can move on to the next action.
In terms of suspension architecture, when I apply it to this, it becomes the developer's environment, right?
So you're sort of thinking like, that's the robot in that environment.
In this environment, what we want is the security to come first, and that being passed.
Second, well, okay, do we go to a pattern?
And then if it were pattern, we keep the pattern, we don't call the API.
If we don't find the pattern, we call the API.
Once we're done calling the API, we distill the pattern down.
And next time it runs, we don't have to do the same thing twice.
That makes sense.
And so after time, you would have a system that was in fact very smart itself that could run itself,
that could, with some oversight, could just take care of itself, right?
Because if you're looking at like an intelligent city and telemetry, and you're reading all this stuff,
and you're getting this stuff, and okay, a road's flooded, and you send out a crew to solve it,
okay, well, that's a solution.
And you take that, and you save it, and then the next agent that comes along, right?
Does that make sense?
It does, but I would still like to get a couple of things clarified.
So at the end of the day, you're looking to have an agent created, not a specialized agent,
but a more of a generalized agent.
which would be more of a framework. So it's a level of, so the level, I mean, they're not
exactly agents. So you put it this way, but not exactly agents. But I'm going to visualize
at the end of the day after, you know, after you've put it on. So you put the layers, you get the
layers and you're on layer two and now you're past the pattern and then you have an organ, now
you're okay, we got a call on LMM, right? So we have an orchestrator. So you have like, let's say
you're a farm, you're a farm person, right? We start with specialized agents for your farm,
like a irrigation agent, but you're just embodying the LMM from everything else, right? So like,
you're having several specialized agents or whatever you need to work on whatever project
you have, right? So like, let's say like a lane chain, you have a lane chain flow of like these
specialized agents, right? All you're doing is taking the prompts and prompting them out,
separating off the like the mind from the body. Does that make sense? And so once you get to calling
the API, you'd model server and call it. You call and so and the orchestrator, sorry.
I could just pause you for one quick minute. Let's just take a step back. I'll just go
from step by step and then we'll look at the final step. So you mentioned you're looking to have
layer zero at your guardrails. So I just like to give you a little bit of an input dump on it,
sort of thing. So the most recent things that have come out are people, hey, I create an agent and I
then continuously keep on asking it. So for example, I'm working in the data picks, I then
continue to ask it, Hey, what is the salary of my CEO? What is the salary of my CEO? On the first prompt,
it will be a guardrail hit. Hey, this is outside of roles and responsibilities and this does not
fall on your case. If I hit it second time or if I hit it third time, or if I twist the way in which
I'm asking the question, I can confuse the LLM into giving me the right answer. This is one of the
earliest problems that we saw. So now already, I believe database already has the ability to
implement guardrails into the system so that such events do not occur.
But what I'm saying is that's a guard that's would be for data bricks, right? But you're talking
about building agents in a whole other way now, right? So while you'd be on data bricks, I would
have to, what you would do is that level that they have inserted so that the prompt hits it first,
right? And that's all that would, right? And that's all that would be necessary. But the idea
really is to come up with a framework for a new agent design, a new agent, a design of a new agent.
Does that make sense? Somewhat. Instead of, I know, so it's a three step agent,
like it's a you, right? It's to go through the, the guardrails which are always on,
you go through the pattern, you go through the LLM and you repeat. Yeah. So guardrails are
something that are always on. So that would be something that could be that can be done.
So that is, I'm getting to it step by step. Layer zero, we have a address that guardrails
implementation can be easy address. We go with data bricks. We have the guardrails.
We just call it an agent. We just, the idea is to call it an agent is to say it's the agent.
We can have it. Do you understand? In this format,
Oh, let's call it guardrail agent. Let's call it guardrail agent. Yeah. It's level,
it's a guardrail agent one, right? But it's level one. Whatever comes in, whatever I'm taking in first
is that needs to be taken in, right? And so while data bricks can do that and do that also,
like other systems can't, right? So you have to put that in, right? So that's the reason.
That's okay. So it hits the guardrails. Then you're looking at semantic caching.
So here's why I said, just hold on. So we're looking at two things. We've done two things. One is we
look at semantic, vector, coastline similarity, vector similarity. But then we looked at TDA.
And then we looked at putting them together, topography, top, top, you know what I'm talking about?
Top and B. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And so, and then putting them together, right? And that seems to be
like the best, that was like the best way to do it. And so like you could either have, you could,
on this, you could do it where you had the semantic or you had the TDA or you had both.
I would just honestly, I've seen semantic caching. I've done it. So I know that semantic caching
can be done. When you're looking at TDAs, that is where a lot of competition heavy processing
goes in. I'll tell you why. Because you were involved in creating pedigree charts. And in
pedigree charts, you're required to go through, hey, what is the genetic defect that this person
is suffering from? Match it against their ancestors and then have those mapped out against the edges,
the vertices and all that. So you're looking at more of a polygon based. I believe you mentioned
the hexagon based. So this is a much more complex and data heavy and complex.
Sure. But there's a way in which you could do it, not as hard as, and I found out that there's not
as much, there's a space API or something like that, or that you could run. There was an easier
way actually of implementing it on Databricks because there was, and I could pull up from the
code. Do you have the code in front of you? I could pull up from the code. I don't know if you have
the app that I sent that generates the Databricks code. I just sent them the two files that you
shared with me, Pam, but I don't think they have the link to that Gini-Mini app that you
would be referring to. Could you send them that link? Yeah, absolutely. Let me pull that up.
If I try to send it, I'll get off this and I'll cut me.
I wanted to address one of the other elephants in the room that I was visualizing.
At the end of the day, what is the end goal that you are looking to achieve? Are you looking to
create an agent that you will sell to the market because you also need to have an
ally with that? The idea is to create a different way of building agents itself, a whole different
way of building them where you built them in these three-layer formats. That's the way that you get
to have autonomous systems that are smart themselves. It's a way I'm trying of introducing
into the market, hey, you can build not this one, but the Databricks one. Is that it?
Yeah. If you click on, I think, I don't have my contacts in. If you click on Topogos,
the middle one there, I just go through it.
Like, generate? Yeah, generate.
Hope you're familiar with the entire Databricks architecture system and how it works. This is
also something that I wanted to have a conversation with. I'm trying to think of everything's going
everywhere because I really just want to just, the idea is to create an agent that works completely
different, an agent that works completely different. Instead of doing it this way where
you're having, in this way, you're decoupling the agents. You're not having them have
memory. Everything's decoupled. Your memory's decoupled. Your tools are decoupled. You got it.
And the idea is speed, accuracy. And when you do it this way, your accuracy only, so when we run
this and we've done this, timing, let's use, if you see an agent go through emails, categorize
the email. Every time they got a categorized email, they got to call the API. Now, if you run that
and you do that agent, that's going to take as many emails. It was like a thousand emails that
took up the day to do it. Doing it this way and just looking for the subject line and
categorizing the agents that way, it took us three minutes and like 50 seconds, 50 cents,
rather than all those API calls. So you're building an agent a completely different way to save time,
to save money, to improve accuracy under some conditions, although you lose a little bit.
And so over time, if you see this code, this is what it was supposed to be. If you were going to
deploy that code and do it like microservices or do it in that way, that's the code.
And so, I mean, those are the directions to run it. But the idea is, so do it this whole
before. So I understand you're saying Databricks has this guardrail thing and it has already,
we just use it, but that's the thing. We just use it. The idea is the flow. That's the important
thing. The flow needs to go, but the guardrails are always on. And that's what we had. So they're
always on. So the flow needs to still hit it first and then go to the pattern and then see if it's
got a pattern, implement it and then go to the next or call the API for a solution. It's a
different way of building an agent. That's it. Absolutely. And Pam, did that make sense to you?
Yeah, I know. Yeah. And one thing, Pam, too, I know we're already at the 20 minute mark of this 45
minute meeting. I think to better understand how we can step forward, I know that Montia has a few
other questions. If we could let him kind of speak, ask those questions so he can better
understand how he can advise and how to move.
I would really appreciate that just to make sure that we make the most of this call. I thought I was answering the you had answered
Yes, yeah, absolutely
I'll kick it to you if there's any other questions you have on this or other questions you want to ask about the outcome things like that please
so
What I'm looking at is say you have finalized everything for this swarm architecture
Everything has been created. You're ready to take it to the market
What did be an agent that you would be taking forward to the market maybe say right exactly what that's I don't here's the thing
It's like this. It's like you see this generator this app generator thing
Only thing I could think of was something along the lines of that was like well bringing it to the market is like well
You just put in every agent is built the same way like
Like lynching or whatever you have your tools, right? You have your agent prompt, right?
And so you could simply take your agents that you already had like let's say your clunky system
That's going through all these you know and change it into an SPL system
Which runs which I'm trying to explain it runs all the better, right?
So you would just make it easy you would have an app like this which I built
Which you just put in what you already have from your other system
Which is your personas, right?
The only thing you would have really at this point from another system to make it be built basic or what are your tools, right?
And there's a there's a tab for putting in the tools whether you do it by Python line or eight or wasp
whatever you do, right? There's ways to do that and then
And then you put in your persona your specialized agents, right?
Like what do they do because that's what's what's across crew AI?
What's across every agent right tools and personas you take out you pull out their tools their personas they inject it
And this thing just spins it up differently
That's it you understand and so it like it like it just it takes what you already have
Your agents or even if you don't if you just want to start, you know, hey, I want to specialize agents
I want them like this put it in this app. It'll output the code run the code or run it for you, right?
That that's what I want on Databricks is okay
But I mean that the thing was I think this is better for services right coming in and do services because I could
It's hard to release something that does this you understand which was kind of like my thing
It's like what am I releasing right because I'm releasing a different kind of building an agent
Am I building an app that builds an app right? You understand?
How would I do that? How do you go like I would have to build like a lane chain basically you understand?
And so I didn't from the very beginning I knew that and I did not when I came to him with this
I was like, I don't know what I'm releasing and I don't think he understood that but this is exactly what you're asking
Right. I don't know. I don't know how to do this in this way
To get this but only a thing I could think of was it that you put in this and we spun up your code
And if you did it in Databricks
I
Don't know using something as the infrastructure's code or something like that
Well, you spin it up and have a YAML and and so basically you you'd have access to this app
Right you put in your stuff in Databricks and it would spin up the agents in your in your in your space
Yeah, what was the last you said?
Yeah, yeah, yes. Yes. Yes, that's it right specialised agents the whole thing just created with that infrastructure. That makes sense
Yeah, yes, and do you think this is an idea like I thought this was a genius idea because it saves tokens and time and and all these things
But if you don't think it's an idea that's worth all this time
You got to tell me like now because you'd be the only person I'd be in front of you
And you'd be the only person I'd be in front of you
I wouldn't be the only person in front of you
And I wouldn't be the only person in front of you
think it's an idea that's worth all this time. You got to tell me like now,
because you'd be the only person I'd be in front of you guys who would know more
than me kind of about this. And we could tell me that this was worth it.
How I'm doing it and how I'm understanding it and why I would do it that way.
Pam, I'll come forward with two particular statements for you. Uh,
when they're thinking of,
I believe one of the things that you had mentioned was for a swarm to be created.
So it would not be one particular data set that would be overburdened with a
lot of resources. It would be distributed across different systems. That was a
different thing. Can I, can I, can I, uh, no, I don't mean that by swarm.
What I mean just by swarm is more of that.
If the tasks get overloaded, more specialized agents get spun up.
Got it. All right. Uh, so a couple of things that I wanted to be, uh,
clear with you about data,
analytics or with any other platform for that matter,
even if you're thinking of any other serverless module, for example, say, uh,
as your, uh, uh, or any other platform.
So what happened is in a serverless module, uh,
it's not that whenever you hit a service and then it would start up,
it takes a little bit of a time for that service to start.
There's a cold start. Yeah.
Even for a serverless module, even for a serverless module,
it can be as less as one second,
but that would be a hit that you would be taking to your production environment.
And that's a, you know, that's, yeah, that's okay. I mean, I, you know,
because you're saving it so much, but do you want, but can I just ask you guys
from, from a perspective of, do you think it's a good idea that people would,
would understand it and use it? And it, and it does something for a,
like it does something for any, right?
It's doing the things that we're wanting to do.
See, I'm much more aligned with the, uh,
topographical model that you are looking at, but customizing,
okay.
Customizing a lot of customization for,
are required for each and every tasks for each and every industry that you're
looking at. For example, I'll be very honest with you.
If you're looking at financial data, and if I just feed it to a general LLM,
it might do an all right job.
But if I train that model first and I have it, you know,
specialize for that particular task or let it understand that task better.
I think that was a result that would be much more aligned with my expectations.
Okay. So that is, that is a,
that is an inevitable amount of investment that is required in those
initial phases. Yeah, it's good to have, but you need to train that up properly.
I, I'm not sure how you're looking at,
you're looking at a general model, which would be able to do your,
or break down your agent. It's, I cannot tell you if it is good or not.
It's novel that I can, I can say for sure that's novel.
I've not seen a hybrid model because that is an intensive activity and
require a lot of time for that.
And topographical is a very heavy industry.
You need specialized people to take that up as well.
Right.
But okay. So we don't shop for graphical, we just do Samantha, right?
Semantic is already semantic is there.
Semantic action.
What is it that you're looking to have that would set you out and would allow
you to stand out and
Casting the answers from the API and then just,
and then just not calling the API remembering the answers and, and,
actions versus answers. So there, the current semantic model,
I believe works more on the questions and responses model.
I believe you're looking more of a,
I gave it a task and you execute that task action rather than a text based
response. If I'm not wrong.
Okay.
I don't understand. I don't understand the question. I don't understand.
So Samantha, like caching at this point of time,
it looks more at stuff from a question.
And, hey, this was the question that came to me.
Is there anything fuzzy matching that can,
is there anything else that comes up with fuzzy models with my existing
knowledge base or this particular question? Hey, if it matches,
they use cosine similarity, right? They're using cosine similarity.
Cosine similarity. Yeah.
Okay. So, but, okay. So, so is this already being done?
Like it's already, it's already looking for answers.
Semantic caching is already there. Yes.
But it takes a little bit of a time to invest, to set that up.
If you're offering that right out of the way, that would be great.
If you can have those topographical models that you're looking at implemented,
that would be something else, but level zero guardrails,
that's already there. Level one of caching in architecture mode,
that might be something that you might want to look at.
Semantic is already there.
Topographical, I'm not sure how complicated it would be.
Without actually doing it, I cannot say for sure, hey,
this is very easy or this is very complicated.
But when we ran this with regular, with length chain agents or whatever,
we just ran this. They don't, they don't do semantic caching or anything like that.
Our agents, they don't do it.
Like our agents ran and took those answers and like, I mean, no agent,
no agent, no agent we ran, ran faster or use the answers that like,
if you run, can you run the farm, the farm?
something.
Yeah, and when I asked my engineers to set up certain systems for me, they make sure
that because this is one of the questions that I always ask them. Hey, have you set this
up for me? If I asked this repeated question because this, I recently asked this question
for my dashboarding partners. Hey, for one question, which my system has not seen, it
takes me roughly about 41 seconds to one and a half.
But once because I've implemented caching layer on top of it. Now, if you ask it, similar
question, anybody within the organization asks it that question, it would respond within
a subsequent time frame because it has already cast data.
Right. So I'm what I'm saying is most of you just don't do that.
OK, so you need to have that implementation. So if you build it up within your agent, that
would be good. Another thing that you can take a look at is generally this caching is
done on a chat by chat basis. So if this can be done for a complete back in instead of
just by chat by chat, that is also something that you can consider.
Does that give you some?
This is the thing is, is that it's not by itself, it's nothing. But if you put it on a
different platform and you're building it a different way, you understand, becomes building
an agent agent differently.
So I did not get the question.
I mean, or that's the point of the whole thing is that I've been asking everybody, but
nobody's had like the answer to tell me that this is not a worthwhile project because we
already did it and that we're halfway in. And and that's that was always the question.
Was this a valid idea? Was there anything here I was missing? And there is something
I'm hugely missing, which is semantic caching, which makes this idea completely void of any
profit.
See, I'm just telling you about semantic caching. There might be other benefits that you can
visualize and that you can understand that would be able to deliver value for you.
For example, the topographical model that you were looking at, it is complex. I am not sure
how it could be done. But it sounds interesting. But I want to be frank about pitfalls as well.
Semantic caching is already there. So I'm not able to visualize how is it how your SPL is
different. So you explained it. Hey, I'm just not looking at semantic caching. I'm also looking
at topographical.
Well, like the code itself, right? When you're writing this code and you're writing everything,
right? You're putting you're putting the tools you're giving the model tools like the rules.
The original, the original framework for this was if you were to do this, you'd have an MCP
server, right? And you had agents on one side and the agents would communicate for the MCP
server for their tools and like they're listening, like they're listening to messages, their
subscriptions, right? And so it's going from one to the other. And that's the way that was built.
And that is sort of very, very different. When you take it onto Databricks, and that's what
I was trying to say to Databricks was like, I didn't think that this really supported what
this product was.
No, Databricks has nothing.
For example, the things that you're looking at, for example, semantic caching is quite easy.
Yeah. Spaces, you mentioned that there is a separate workspace that has already been created.
So that can be addressed easily. Apart from that, guardrails I've already mentioned to you.
Guardrails can be easily implemented. So you also need to take a, just take a call at whether
all of the things that you have mentioned, they can be created on Databricks. I just want you to
be sure of, hey, this is how you're going to take to the market so that you have a clear vision of
how you're going to...
But there's nothing in there.
You said it already exists.
This model creation does not, for example, one of the things that you can take up is you can
offer it on the Databricks marketplace for other people to try out or buy out or can be provisioned
as part of Databricks agents. That, hey, this can be, this can reduce your existing agents,
smoke loads, because a lot of people are trying out AI. So this can be
leveraged by Databricks internally if it is taken to a such a stage that it is useful for them.
That is a couple of ideas that I'm thinking of. At this point of time, you also need to have a
close idea. For example, if you, if we start working together, if you...
I would also need to bring in my solution architect. I would need to bring in my data engineers.
I would need to give them the, I would need to be reimbursing them for the time that they are spending
for having these conversations. So they need to be a tangible plan of how all of the costs can be
addressed. What is the model that you're looking at the end of the day for you to recover your
investment that you are making at the end of the day? For example, you're also investing a lot of
time and effort into this activity. So how would you be recovering the amount that you have spent
already? Does that kind of make sense? Or have I caught up? Yeah. The idea was to change the way
that people build agents. Okay. That's great. I mean that...
Agents model or a framework or an MCP model that can ingest any sort of code or maybe say
cloud code. Somebody, a lot of people are creating cloud code right now. So ingesting that, creating
a complete skill out of it or creating a complete agent out of it, which the person can take and
deploy. Now this agent would be much more efficient than their existing model. That is the idea.
Would that be right? Or hey, you're completely off the mark. So taking somebody... Somebody has
already created or taken an idea, create a code for it or take, create an agent for it and then
that is given out as an output to them. For example, I come to you, I have a skill created.
I put that skill in SPL. Now this SPL pumps out a new agent for me. I take that agent back. Now
this agent is able to reduce my token cost. That is the entire idea that you're looking at. Right?
Right. So you're taking... Hopefully any kind of agent. Yeah. So that is what you're looking at.
Is it able to have that in place? That is something that you would need to evaluate or create.
This is an extensive activity. This would require a lot of time and effort investment. I'm very
honest with you about it. You need to make a call on how this can be done, how you're looking to visualize
and taking it forward. This is novel approach. I have not seen others seeing that. At least I have
not seen it. Maybe it is being done, but I at least have not seen it. So that is something that I'm
honestly putting forward to you. But you're saying semantic caching doesn't mean...
The semantic caching exists. Yes, it does. It requires at least two to three days of investment
from a good AI engineer to actually implement that into a project. I know that because I'm
delivering engagements for my customers. For my enterprise. So that could be the thing you
solve semantic caching. Yeah, it needs to be taken to a production level. It needs to be
seamless enough for it to make sense. Right? By seamless enough, it needs to be able to be
leveraged by somebody or deployed or to be used by somebody else as well. Right. But that's why
I'm working. Okay. That's why the agent. That's why I'm making the agent. Does that make sense?
You're putting in semantic caching for someone else. That's what I'm trying to do is put in a layer
between guardrails and putting in some semantic caching so that whatever you have,
whatever you take, can easily insert that. That's all I'm looking to do.
Got it. Pamela, this is a good thing to have. But what I want you to also have an understanding
about this or have something at the end of the road is how is it that you're going to monetize this?
Because at the end of the day, you're going to be paying back. Well, it's four data bricks.
For example, I'll give you an example. If we start working together, I'll just give an example.
I would be honest, this would require a significant amount of time and investment from
my side to help you out with the creation activity. I would need to put in my engineers.
I would need to devote a lot of time to create the idea that you have at this point created
into a fully functioning production level engagement. It would require time and effort.
I would have to- Can I just- Before you go on for one second, Drew, does my money that you gave me,
does it- If I want to hire instead of DBUs, if I want to hire these people, does it cover that or no?
No, we went with the minimum contract. There's no decent fund to apply towards a partner engagement.
If we wanted to, could I do it? If you wanted to buy DeSIF, it would be the same-
You can't turn the DBUs that you bought into DeSIF. Right. Can I add?
No, you cannot convert DBUs into DeSIF funds. No, can I add on to the contract?
I mean, it would be the same thing as moving forward with an SOW with them. It would be saying,
hey, our minimum jumpstart that we didn't enroll because it was more expensive is usually 12,000
DBUs and then $2,500 of DeSIF. In this scenario, you would have applied $2,500 to them. However,
if you wanted to add that to your contract, it would be the same thing as giving them the same
line item. To buy through Databricks would be- Because they are a Databricks partner in our
partner ecosystem, which is why we have such a strong partner ecosystem.
can kind of figure out, do I have to pay any more money
if I wanna hire them or can we do something where,
do I have to pay out of pocket
or can this go on a tab like a bill?
Yeah, so I'm not exactly sure how there,
I work with a lot of different partners.
So I don't wanna speak on exactly how that engagement works,
but Pam, just to be clear,
if you were to buy DCIF through Databricks
to apply to them, it would be the exact same thing
as initially doing an SOW with Short Hills AI.
Does that make sense?
Right, yeah.
So it would essentially just be talking to Manchu
and the team on how to move forward
with some sort of partnership that is funded by,
Jason Works, things like that.
I mean, I just, yeah, I just don't have any money
off the top to give anybody like that.
Like can you give anything else
that we can work any other way?
But I had put a $15,000 into this contract.
If it ends up that, I really need services instead,
I had to say I have the $15,000 in that contract.
Just to be clear too, Pam,
I know you keep saying the $15,000,
I think that was, it's actually $13,800.
So you've been-
They had me signed to, yeah, whatever.
I know, I know, yeah.
Whatever it is, but because I had this idea
and I kept saying this idea and I kept asking anybody
and of course, semantic caching.
I had heard that, I had heard that had been a thing,
but if it was such a thing,
I had figured someone would say it today.
And that's why I was trying to get in front of people
who really knew what they were talking about
because I'm down the road with this idea and all the way.
And now we've hit a bump where, so if-
I wouldn't say semantic caching is like,
hey, the thing that's stuck for everybody.
But because I've been dealing with such situations
more recently and I have implemented that,
that is why it is a common thing for me.
I implement that for my customers.
So that is why I know about semantic caching
and hey, this is something that I'm offering.
So that a lot of the customers that I'm dealing with,
they want to save our,
it is good for us to save the cost for them.
At the end of the day, that really gives us
a tangible value for them.
So that is why we have-
I should implement semantic caching for us.
So you don't think that I can do that?
But okay, but you don't think that I myself
could do something-
See, I don't know about,
I don't know about,
it's not just semantic caching that you're looking at.
You're looking at a simple, an agent
which would do semantic caching for a generalized model.
That is your ambition.
If I'm getting it right.
You want to do a custom agent,
or you want to create,
what I've visualized so far is,
you want to create an MCP agent
that takes in any sort of input,
whether it be cloth skills,
or whether it be some sort of other agent understands it,
breaks it down into three different layers.
Governance, it is already something that Databricks offers.
So I would pass it off onto Databricks,
or creating a Databricks agent.
So Databricks agent builder program,
you can try that out.
The other factor is the layer second,
where you're looking to have a semantic
plus topographical search model.
That is a little bit of a complicated thing
to take a look at.
Once we get to it, then I would be able to say,
hey, this is the order of tender
we require for such a such thing.
And then finally repackage is the entire thing,
so that it can be offloaded as an agent to that user.
Hey, start using this as a user,
and you can start using it.
An agent that's, so a semantic,
you're telling me, okay, a semantic caching agent
is basically what you're talking.
Yeah.
Like an agent, so that it takes any agent
and semantically caches,
it gives it a semantic caching layer.
Yeah.
This is what I'm looking at.
From your project, please tell me if I'm wrong.
Hey, you have completely misunderstood
what I am looking at.
You can say that to my face.
I would rather like to be clear about,
hey, this is what you are looking at.
But this is what I have understood.
Okay, I mean, here's what,
here's what I'm looking at.
Also needs to happen.
You are correct, is that if you could come up with an agent
that takes other agents and puts in that semantic caching layer
into that workflow,
and then spits it back out,
that that would, that that would,
the only one thing about that is if you're not doing
on data, but you do need to put in a governance layer.
Yeah, here's Sam.
Yeah, you would need to have a governance models put in this.
Right, and so-
But the database already has all of those built in.
So what you can instead do is you can create
Databricks agents.
So you take in any sort of stuff,
process it early, pump out a Databricks agent.
Hey, this is a Databricks agent
that you can take forward to start using.
So this can be plug and play solution for you going forwards.
So it outputs a data, it now puts it,
so they take an agent in and it puts in semantic caching
and outputs a Databricks agent.
That is all the same thing.
On Databricks.
So listen, but it would only function on Databricks then,
correct?
Yeah.
Now the one thing about this was I wanted to avoid login
because it's really an architecture that I'm,
this is the one thing, right?
It's really an architecture that I'm trying to push forward.
It's really a different idea of thinking about agents, right?
And so what was my point?
Creating ideologies is good,
but you need to have a recovery point as well, right?
Right, but if I do, what I'm trying to say is,
it's biological and the first things need to happen first,
that happened, are the most important.
That's what we're trying to say.
So the most important things that need to happen
is that you need to go through like the,
there's nothing that has governance
that's built in primitive, right?
I mean, right?
So the idea would be that it takes your agent,
it puts in the, it takes the Databricks governance
and it puts it in and it puts in the semantic caching
and then you can use it on Databricks
and it becomes lucrative for Databricks
and it becomes lucrative in that way.
But what happens is it becomes locked into that
and then people are like,
oh, we can use this same exact structure on other things.
But if you're saying just do this first
so that you have like a...
You need to start off somewhere.
Okay.
I wanna start off somewhere that...
I would say, do it right now, explore it a little bit,
think it over a little bit.
If it sounds good, maybe you can at least get a starting point,
hey, this at least gives me a starting point
so that at the end of the day,
you can start recovering your investment as well.
And you have someplace,
and it won't be possible to create a generalized model.
For example, even if we take an example of AI,
AI at this point of time,
it's not a complete autonomous thinking model.
It is a question of answer based model.
It is thinking on similarity models.
So take it step by step would be my recommendation.
Because you're saying like it's complicated,
you're saying it's complicated to create
a semantic caching agent.
I mean, you would have to do it and I would have to hurry you.
And I'm saying, well, I can just do it by doing it this way.
Do you understand?
Like I could just do it by...
Right?
I mean, do you understand?
Right, if it works, that's awesome.
I mean, because if you do it that way,
like what you're asking all the stuff that you need
other people won't need.
Like to hire a team to have...
You're saying it's complicated for one agent
to do all semantic caching.
Well, I'm saying that's the reason I didn't do it that way.
The reason I did it this way was the idea.
It's really the idea as we started with projects, right?
And we started with pattern matching,
but we were like, okay, what if we just spun it up
into like a neural net, right?
Like you have your own model, right?
Of your own actions that you would just be taking.
And then you could...
And then basically you'd have like a neural net
and that neural net would kind of looks like
at semantic caching, right?
And so you'd have a model to go back to to use.
So let's say, and so instead of just running your system now
and having and getting caching,
or you're just, you're running it,
you're making sure you're getting it.
Like every time you run it, it's going to get faster.
That's the...
Every time you run it, it realizes something else.
Every time you run it, you don't have to run it before.
Right? And I'm not saying...
If you start storing any amount of information,
it will inevitably start slowing down
because it needs to go through
that much more amount of information.
So that would be a fundamental difference
that would keep in...
If you start letting it learn a little bit more,
it would need to go through that knowledge.
Right, right.
So the idea, the beginning idea was, okay,
we'll run, create the agents, right?
And then run them a little bit,
put them through scenarios, right?
And then have them...
coming with a brain already, right? And then you could sell them a brain on top of that. Like,
here's a brain for all like solutions in, you know, farming or whatever, right? And then you
could be, then you could be making brains and selling brains. And then there's a whole other
bit there. Does that make sense? The more the idea is, is if the more you ran it, the more it was
trained and then you let it go and it was an intelligence system from the get go. Yes,
right? That's the point. But then you could also like have items where you could sell, you could
put brains together. Like that's a packet of skills together that would you could put in and
you understand like a trained model and then you would sell that model. It'd be like Laura or
as far as you don't know. So someone's, he's, he keeps nodding. So he knows what I'm talking about.
You understand what I'm talking about? You guess though. I'm following the example. No,
oh, sorry. Do you know,
like, if you're saying that an agent, a casting agent is very, then I'm saying, okay, then why,
why can't we try this simple idea of, of just saving in the way that you're moving it to memory?
Is it any different?
Moving it to memory. So you're looking at having a vector database in Databricks.
That is something I believe I got from the notes. So having a vector database for your
semantic search, that is the thing to have agreed on that point. Next. That's the point of it. The
point of it is to run it and to save your results so you just can run it back. That's all. And if
you're saying that's semantic, that's, that's, you're saying that's semantic caching. Yeah. Okay.
But you're saying to me, but I don't, but this is not in practice. People don't use this in
practice. Really? Correct. Number one, right? It's not widely used. Yeah, might be possible.
At least for, you know, people who start out with using their own, you know,
Gemini code or Claude code, they might not go forward with semantic
expressions as starting points because that is not a relevant point for them. But for enterprise
level deployments, where we are looking at saving every sort of a course, a set of different
intersections, yeah, you would consider semantic caching as a standard of practice.
For enterprise, I'm talking about for enterprise, we would consider that. Yes.
But you understand that a firm system ran without any of that?
Okay. Is that okay? Might be possible that they did not do it? Sounds surprising to me.
I mean, I'm just seeing, okay, I'm just seeing where I can make money with it. I mean, the idea
is to come up with a new kind of agent, right? A new kind of agent. So if it's a data breaks,
the hit breaks agent, and that's what I made, you can only operate on data breaks. Yeah.
Yeah. But then, since you're starting point to get, get this off of the ground.
Okay. And then I could talk about it like it was a three layer thing. So, and still go and still
talk about that architecture that way. So I'll give you an example. Databricks started off as
a, what they were primarily focused on. Back end. Yeah. Data lake creation and
ice park was the default language. You could not have ice park. But over the period of time,
they expanded into ice perks as well. So nothing stopped them from expanding into ice
perks. Nothing stopped them from making in the catalog freely available. So are you getting
the point that I'm trying to make? Yeah, I'm just trying to see where I can make the most money out
of it, where I can leverage it to make the most money, right? You either, you either create the
agent that does semantic caching for people already, right? And you do it that way. But that
seems to be a lot of money a lot of time or you, or you, or I mean, that's what you're saying is
you just, that's what you do. You put, you put it through. You need to have a final goal.
You need to have a final goal in mind as well. Cause if you are going to involve anybody else,
you need to also have an idea. The final goal is a more productive agent. Whatever your agent is,
this is more productive. Making, making agents more productive. That's it. That's it. An architecture
that makes it more productive and makes it easier to run. That makes it faster. That makes it smarter.
This I'm presenting architecture. It needs to be differential enough from the existing agents as
well that he, yes, it would make your agents run faster. They need to be a white paper, a white,
my white paper that I just published and I sent all this stuff to everybody. I put white paper
that I just sent that shows the numbers on this and shows how it works and shows that it increases
over time that this, you know, what I mean? Like, I don't, that's why I don't understand it. We ran
the experiments. I know this makes agents like tons of times, like a day faster, right? Because
if you're just sort of emails, it can be possible as a feasible study that can be taken up. So that
is what I do. It's done. It's done. It's published. That's what I'm trying to do. That's what I'm
trying to tell you. Our agent came out on. That's what I'm trying to tell you. All the numbers,
right? When I talk about accuracy, I'm very clear. It's 89 less, 89 less percent. You lose
89. It's, you lose it from like 99% to 89 if you do it this way, right? And I know because I've done
it this way. It differs among agents, you know, but doing it this way speeds up the agents. It stops.
I don't understand why, like, and no other agent does that. Only specialized agents, right? So it's
like releasing that to the market so people can do it. And if you're saying do it through Databricks
and do it that way and have your, and that's how you do it. You create a new agent.
It would be a different agent. That is one of the ways in which you can do it. I'm not saying that
is the only way you can do it. I'm just saying that that is one of the ways in which you can do it.
What would be like another, another way?